Alors, je sais que vous vous demandez –
laissez-moi y répondre : oui, un peu comme Melinda Gates –
(Rires)
mais avec beaucoup moins d'argent.
Elle a conduit des actions philanthropiques dans notre communauté
en se basant sur un concept appelé « isirika ».
Elle a soutenu l'instruction de centaines d'enfants
et elle en a invité beaucoup à venir habiter chez nous
afin qu'ils accèdent à l'école.
Elle a mobilisé des ressources pour construire un centre local de soins
et l'aile consacrée à la maternité a été baptisée en sa mémoire.
Mais, le plus important,
c'est que la communauté l’a aimée pour ses qualités d'organisatrice,
parce qu'elle a organisé la communauté,
et plus spécifiquement les femmes,
pour trouver des solutions
à tout ce qui manquait.
Elle a accompli tout ça en suivant l'isirika.
Laissez-moi vous répéter encore ce mot :
isirika.
C'est à votre tour. Dites-le avec moi.
Public : Isirika.
Musimbi Kanyoro : Merci.
Ce mot vient de ma langue maternelle, le Maragoli,
parlée dans l'ouest du Kenya,
et maintenant, vous parlez ma langue.
(Rires)
L'isirika est un mode de vie pragmatique
qui prône autant la charité,
que l'aide
et la philanthropie.
Le principe de l'isirika,
c'est de dire clairement à tout le monde
que vous prenez soin de votre sœur –
et oui,
vous prenez soin de votre frère.
C'est la responsabilité mutuelle de prendre soin les uns des autres.
En français, on le traduirait littéralement par « générosité égale »,
mais, son sens philosophique profond,
c'est de s'occuper tous les uns des autres.
Comment se manifeste réellement l'isirika ?
J'ai été élevée dans une communauté agricole
de l'ouest du Kenya.
Je me souviens très bien des nombreuses fois
où les voisins allaient chez un autre voisin –
un voisin malade –
et cueillaient sa récolte pour lui.
Je suivais partout ma mère aux événements de la communauté
et aux rassemblements des femmes.
J'ai discuté de la vaccination à l'école,
de la construction du centre médical
et de choses importantes –
comme récupérer les graines pour les prochaines semailles.
Souvent, la communauté se réunissait
et récoltait de l'argent pour financer les études de l'enfant d'un voisin –
pas seulement au Kenya,
mais aussi dans des universités à l'étranger.
Nous avons un chirurgien.
Le premier chirurgien de mon pays venait de ce village rural.
(Applaudissements)
Donc...
l'isirika nous a permis de nous ouvrir à tous.
Nous, les enfants, étions aux côtés des adultes,
à donner de l'argent pour contribuer,
et nos noms étaient inscrits dans le registre de la communauté,
exactement comme celui de chaque adulte.
Et puis, j'ai grandi,
je suis allée dans des universités de mon pays et à l'étranger,
j'ai reçu des diplômes ici et là,
je suis devenue organisée,
j'ai accepté des postes à l'étranger,
j'ai œuvré pour le développement,
le travail humanitaire
et la philanthropie.
Et très vite,
l'isirika a commencé à s'amenuiser.
Il s'est dissipé,
puis a tout bonnement disparu.
A chaque endroit,
j'ai appris un nouveau vocabulaire.
Le vocabulaire des donateurs et des bénéficiaires.
Le vocabulaire pour mesurer l'impact,
le retour sur investissement,
les projets et les programmes.
Les communautés comme celle de mon enfance
ont été considérées comme des « populations pauvres et vulnérables ».
La recherche mentionne ces communautés quand elle parle
des gens vivant avec moins d'un dollar par jour,
et elles deviennent les cibles des programmes d'éradication de la pauvreté.
Et d'ailleurs,
ce sont les cibles du premier
Objectif de Développement Durable des Nations Unies.
Alors, je suis vraiment motivée
par trouver des solutions à la pauvreté
et aux autres grands problèmes mondiaux,
qui sont bien réels.
Je pense, cependant, que nous pouvons mieux faire,
et nous pourrions mieux faire en adoptant l'isirika.
Laissez-moi vous dire comment.
D'abord, l'isirika témoigne de notre humanité partagée.
Pour n'importe laquelle de nos actions,
on part du postulat qu'on est humains ensemble.
Quand on commence à être humains ensemble,
on regarde les autres différemment.
Vous ne voyez pas d'abord le réfugié,
ni la femme d'abord,
ni la personne handicapée d'abord.
Vous voyez un être humain avant toute chose.
C'est le principe de regarder d'abord la personne.
Et quand nous le faisons,
nous valorisons leurs idées,
nous apprécions leur contribution –
petite ou grande.
Et nous estimons ce qu'ils nous apportent.
C'est le principe de l'isirika.
Je veux seulement imaginer ce qui se passerait
si tout le monde dans cette salle –
médecin, parent,
avocat, philanthrope,
qui que vous soyez –
si vous adoptiez l'isirika
pour en faire votre valeur par défaut.
Que pourrait-on accomplir les uns pour les autres ?
Que pourrait-on accomplir pour l'humanité ?
Que pourrait-on accomplir pour la paix ?
Que pourrait-on accomplir pour la médecine ?
Laissez-moi vous donner quelques indices,
car je vais vous demander de m'accompagner
dans ce processus de reconstruction et de récupération de l'isirika.
Tout d'abord, vous devez avoir la conviction
qu'il n'y a qu'une seule humanité,
que nous n'avons qu'une seule planète
et qu'il n'y a pas d'autre option à ça.
Aucun mur ne sera assez haut
pour séparer l'humanité.
Alors, renoncez aux murs.
Oubliez-les.
(Applaudissements)
Il n'y a aucune planète de secours.
C'est très important.
Que les choses soient claires,
passons à l'étape suivante.
La deuxième étape : souvenez-vous,
pour l'isirika, chaque idée compte.
Les ponts sont faits de grands piliers
et aussi de petits clous.
Chaque idée compte –
petite ou grande.
Et troisièmement,
selon l'isirika,
les plus favorisés ont la chance de donner plus.
C'est un honneur de donner plus.
(Applaudissements)
Et c'est le moment, pour les femmes, de donner plus aux autres femmes.
C'est le moment de donner plus aux femmes.
Mes parents, quand ils ont accueilli d'autres enfants chez nous,
ne nous ont pas demandé la permission.
Ils nous ont bien fait comprendre qu'ils avaient une responsabilité
parce qu'ils étaient allés à l'école
et qu'ils gagnaient de l'argent.
Ils nous ont expliqué qu'on devait comprendre
que leur prospérité ne nous donnait pas de droits.
Je pense que c'est un sage précepte tiré de l'isirika.
Aujourd'hui, je pense que nous pourrions utiliser ce bon sens dans chaque culture,
dans chaque endroit,
en transmettant à la génération future ce que nous pouvons réaliser ensemble.
J'ai,
au fil des années,
retrouvé l'isirika dans beaucoup d'endroits.
Mais, ce qui me motive vraiment aujourd'hui
pour adopter l'isirika,
c'est le travail que je fais avec des femmes dans le monde entier
dans le cadre du Fonds mondial pour les femmes,
des fonds destinés aux femmes
et des mouvements de femmes dans le monde entier.
En travaillant avec des femmes,
vous évoluez tous les jours
car vous pratiquez le concept de l'isirika avec elles, dans ce qu'elles font.
Dans mon travail,
nous faisons confiance aux femmes dirigeantes et à leurs idées.
Nous les appuyons en les finançant pour qu'elles puissent se développer,
se construire
et s'épanouir au sein de leurs communautés.
En 1990, une femme est venue au Fonds mondial avec une grande idée –
une Mexicaine nommée Lucero Gonzalez.
Elle voulait lancer un fonds pour soutenir un mouvement
qui serait enraciné dans les communautés du Mexique.
Et elle a reçu une subvention de 7 500 dollars.
Aujourd'hui, 25 ans plus tard,
Semillas – ce fonds s'appelle ainsi –
a levé et dépensé,
au sein de sa communauté,
17,8 millions de dollars.
(Applaudissements)
Il a touché plus de deux millions de personnes
et il fonctionne avec un groupe de 600 000 femmes au Mexique.
Lors du dernier tremblement de terre,
il était tellement bien implanté
qu'il a pu rapidement évaluer, au sein de sa communauté et en dehors,
quels étaient les besoins à court terme et à long terme.
Et je vous le dis,
dans les heures les plus sombres du Mexique,
Semillas sera toujours là
avec les communautés, avec les femmes,
pour très longtemps.
Et c'est ce dont je vous parle :
être capable d'appuyer les idées de groupes
ancrés dans leur environnement.
Il y a 30 ans,
il y avait très peu de financements que les femmes recevaient directement
dans leurs communautés.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes rendus à 168 fonds pour les femmes
dans le monde entier,
dont une centaine est basée dans ce pays.
Et ils soutiennent –
(Applaudissements)
ils soutiennent des organisations locales de femmes –
des organisations communautaires dirigées par des femmes et des jeunes filles.
Ensemble, nous avons été capables,
collectivement,
de donner un milliard de dollars à des organisations dirigées par des femmes.
(Applaudissements)
Mais le vrai défi commence aujourd'hui.
Le vrai défi commence aujourd'hui
car nous voyons partout des femmes s'organiser selon le concept de l'isirika,
y compris des femmes au sein de TED.
Car l'isirika est la sagesse intemporelle qui habite les communautés.
On le retrouve dans les groupes autochtones,
dans les groupes ruraux.
Ce que l'isirika inculque aux gens,
c'est la capacité à faire confiance
et à faire avancer les choses.
Je voudrais donc partager avec vous trois choses que j'ai apprises
grâce à mon travail.
Premièrement, si vous voulez résoudre les grands problèmes mondiaux,
investissez dans les femmes et les jeunes filles.
(Applaudissements)
Elles font non seulement fructifier l'investissement,
tout en prenant soin de chacun au sein du groupe.
Elles ne pensent pas qu'à leurs besoins, mais aussi à ceux de leurs enfants,
à ceux du reste du groupe,
à ceux des personnes âgées,
et le plus important,
elles se protègent elles-mêmes –
ce qui est très important –
et elles protègent leur groupe.
Des femmes qui savent comment se protéger
savent ce que signifie changer les choses.
Ma deuxième raison pour investir dans les femmes et les jeunes filles,
c'est parce que c'est la chose la plus intelligente que vous pouvez faire
à ce moment précis.
Et si nous allons avoir
plus de 350 000 milliards de dollars
en 2030,
ces dollars doivent passer par les mains des femmes.
Et donc, j'ai grandi avec l'isirika.
Ma mère était l'isirika.
Elle n'était pas un projet ou un programme.
Et aujourd'hui, je vous transmets l'isirika.
Pour que vous puissiez le partager avec votre famille,
avec vos amis
et avec votre communauté.
Et pour que vous adoptiez l'isirika comme mode de vie –
comme mode de vie pragmatique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)